This election made me feel as
excited as Steve Harvey.
Hosting Family Feud when there's
two white families that day.
But now that it's over let's
stop saying the two candidates
were similar.
Hilary may be everything that's
wrong with politics.
But Trump is everything that is
wrong with humanity.
The difference between them is
the difference between.
Getting fucked in the ass by a
person who knows how to properly
fuck you in the ass.
Because they watched someone
else do it well for eight years.
And getting fucked in the eye
socket by a belligerent failure.
Who at the age of 70 decided-
"Hey it mught be fun to start
fucking people in the eye
socket"
And honestly getting fucked in
the eye socket doesn't seem like
the worst idea right now.
Cos at least then I won't have
to see just how terrible things
are gonna get.
Certain people don't get
Superman.
Including the entire team of
people.
That are currently making his
movies.
They think Superman is just a
goofy dope with his underwear on
the outside.
That gets outshined by any other
hero on screen.
Not true!
Superman is a hard working
illegal alien.
From far far away.
That got adopted by two nice old
white poeple from Kansas.
That didn't even teach him to be
racist.
That's way more impressive than
a sad billionare named Bruce.
Who's only power is not being
able to let go of some sad shit.
That happened 30 years ago.
Get over it!
Award shoes are overly long.
Masturbatory.
And overlook great outside of
the box projects.
Because they dont feature
slavery....Aids...
Or the Holocost.
But they aren't meanigless.
For every person that wins.
There's a pile of loosers.
Soalking in tuxedos knowing they
won't get the perfect kind of
blowjob.
You only receive when you thank
your wife in an acceptance
speech.
And there is a lot of meeting
and watching people who look
better than you.
And make more money than you be
sad.
And feel like as much as a
failure as you are.
Which is a really positive way
of thinking about it.